- Let's see if we can figure
out what 4 divided by 2/3 is,
and like always, pause this video,
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
Well, one way to approach it is to realize
that this is the same thing
as 4 times the reciprocal of 2/3.
So it'd be 4 times 3
over 2, and what is this
going to be equal to?
You could pause the video
again if you're so inspired.
Well, what you need to realize
is this is the same thing.
4 could be written as
a fraction as 4 over 1.
So 4 over 1 times 3/2,
and we've multiplied fractions before.
To do that, you just
multiply the numerators.
4 times 3 is equal to 12,
and you multiply the denominators.
1 times 2 is equal to 2.
12/2, well that's the same thing as 6.
This is the same thing as 12 divided by 2,
but a key question is
why does this make sense.
You know, I said dividing by something is
the same thing as multiplying
by the reciprocal.
And to think about that,
let's draw four wholes.
So let me draw it in the same red color.
So let's say that this is
one whole right over here.
This is two wholes.
This is three wholes.
And then this is four wholes.
So I have four wholes there.
And imagine splitting it up into groups
that are each 2/3 of a whole.
So actually, let me just divide everything
into 1/3s real fast.
So I'm gonna divide everything
into 1/3s, into 1/3s.
So I'm gonna make each
group a different color.
So here's one group that is 2/3.
Here's another group that is 2/3.
Here is another group that
is, or another section,
that I could say, that represents 2/3.
Here is another section
that represents 2/3.
Here is another section.
Folks, let me do that
in a different color.
Here is,
here is another section
that can represent 2/3
if I take those two blue 1/3s together.
That's 2/3, and then last but
not least, I have another 2/3.
So how many sections that
are each 2/3 large do I have?
Well, I have one,
and then these is two,
and then I have three,
and then I have four,
and then these two combined make a,
make my fifth section that is 2/3 large,
and then finally, I have six.
So I have six.
I can take four wholes and split it
into six equal sections that
are each 2/3 of a whole.
So 4 divided into sections
that are 2/3 of a whole,
you will get 6 sections.